- Hey dude, what's up?
- Dude?
- Dude.
Dude.
- I'm gonna (bleep) him, dude.
- Dude.
Dude.
- Dude
- Two dudes go down on us.
Dudes.
Dude.
- Dude.
- Dude!
- As the dudes go down
on us at the same time.
- Yeah, dude.
- Dude.
- Dude, I joined
the Moil High Club.
- Dude, I've been waiting
for the bathroom forever.
- Dude.
- Dudes.
(yells)
- Dude!
- Dude.
- Dudes.
- Two dudes...
- Dude.
- Dudes.
- I love pizza, dude.
- Dude.
- Dude!
- You white dudes
are figuring out
that the jig is (bleep) up!
- Dude.
- Okay.
- Oh, dude.
- Dude.
- [Abby] Dudes.
- Dudes.
- Dude.
- [Ilana] Dude.
- Oh my God, dude!
- Dude.
Dude.
- His dick, dude!
- Dude.
Dude.
- Gentle-Dudes.
- Dude.
Dude.
Dude!
- Oh (bleep), dude!
- Dude.
Dude, Tinder, dude.
Dude!
- Dude.
- Dudes.
Yeah, dude, carpe day-um.
- Dude
Dude.
- Dude.
- Ab-dude.
- Dudes.
- The world is good, dude.
- Dude.
Dude.
- I know.
- [Narrator] Dude, the new
season of Broad City is coming.
Summer 2017.
- Yes, dude!
Yes!
- Dude, I would follow you
into hell, brother.